If you go back and revisit some of the television
you watched as a kid, you might be surprised
about what networks used to regularly throw
in front of you.
Some of our most beloved childhood favorites
and cult classics were actually pretty terrifying
in their own ways...
Here are some TV shows that gave us nightmares
as kids.
Are You Afraid Of The Dark?
Probably every kid's favorite scary show in
the '90s, Are You Afraid of the Dark?
included quite a few nightmare-inducing moments.
For example, "The Tale of the Pinball Wizard,"
which kept probably kept some kids away from
arcades for a few years…
"Excuse me sir."
"Hey, Ah, Ah"
How about "The Tale of the Dark Music," which
proved that monsters living in closets are
pretty creepy — especially when they're
being polite?
"Hello Andy, come on in."
Even watching it today, there are some pretty
horrific concepts; alien abductors, the old
lady down the road being a witch, ghost clowns
— these terrors and more could all be found
on cable TV, and during many sleepless nights.
The Nightmare Room
"When the lights fade and the moon rises
anything can happen."
The WB's version of Are You Afraid of the
Dark?, The Nightmare Room also included a
splash of The Twilight Zone, and it was occasionally
just as scary as both.
Based on the book series by R.L. Stine, some
of the episodes were truly disturbing.
Like "Dear Diary, I'm Dead," for instance
— because nothing's better than reminding
children of their own impending mortality
and the fact that they may die at any moment!
Many of the episodes dealt with ghosts and
haunted things, but aliens and cursed summer
camps also figured in.
Unfortunately, the show proved short-lived,
only lasting one season.
Goosebumps
Also a product of the kid-warping mind of
R.L. Stine, the Goosebumps series of books
was too scary to read after dark, and the
TV show didn't disappoint either.
Perhaps the creepiest part of the series was
Slappy, an evil ventriloquist dummy that was
basically a slightly less murder-y version
of Chucky.
Slappy was created out of coffin wood by an
ancient sorcerer, and was hell-bent on enslaving
children...like you do.
"You and I are one now, inseparable.
You are my slave."
Puppets are creepy enough as it is…
"Ahhh"
"I won't hurt you."
But we could never look at puppets the same
way after Slappy had his way with us
"Hey that dummy can't hurt you.
He's not even alive.
He's dead"
"Ahhhh"
Eerie, Indiana
Another one-season show, Eerie, Indiana, was
like an X-Files for kids, with all the horror
intact, and no bizarre alien pregnancies.
Many of the episodes revolved around urban
legends like Bigfoot and other strange beings...with
the occasional gruesome death of a classmate,
resulting in a haunted heart transplant.
Because again, reminding kids that life is
fragile is probably the fastest way to ruin
the rest of their lives.
Doctor Who
Today, the British science fiction series
Doctor Who enjoys plenty of critical acclaim
and mainstream fandom, but when the show first
aired in 1963, it was intended to be an educational
program.
By the time it hit its stride in the '70s
and '80s, it looked like the taxpayer-funded
production that it was: low-budget, limited
sets, and guys in cheap suits portraying aliens
and monsters.
Still, the show's deadly serious tone, combined
with relentless rubber creatures who spoke
in unusual accents, hey, I take offence to
that, made the show fairly creepy for kids
who snuck out of bed to see what their parents
were watching.
Courage the Cowardly Dog
Pit a timid, purple dog against a parade of
surreal monsters at a farmhouse in the middle
of nowhere and you have Courage the Cowardly
Dog.
The Cartoon Network original series launched
in 1999 and had no shortage of supernatural
malevolence, from rooms made entirely of guts
to mind-control parasites.
Oh, and the occasional end of all life on
Earth as well.
Because the only thing better than reminding
kids that they're going to die is reminding
them that everyone else is going to die, too,
Yay.
Slim Goodbody
This recurring series of short segments, which
ran during Captain Kangaroo in the '70s, was
supposed to teach kids good habits, like why
it's important to exercise and that vegetables
are healthy.
But creator and Slim Goodbody actor John Burstein
went about doing that in a questionable way:
by wearing a form-fitting, flesh-colored unitard
decorated with realistically rendered pictures
of the inner workings of the human body.
Organs, bones, veins, blood, guts... everything.
Unfortunately, Slim Goodbody wound up looking
like a serial killer who glues his victim's
organs to his body.
Amazingly, Burstein still tours schools with
his Slim Goodbody character.
More amazingly, schools let this guy in the
door.
"I'm wonderful and special."
You know what else is wonderful and special?
Keeping your organs on the inside of your
body, you freak.
"Ahhh"
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
shows freaked you out as a kid...